Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In a previous episode, we discussed a technique
where we could specify a low-quality image
of a test subject, and a photo of a different
person.
What happens then is that the algorithm transformed
our test subject into that pose.
With an other algorithm, we can transfer our
facial gestures onto a different target subject.
And this new method does something completely
different — here, we can copy a full-body
movement from a video and transfer it onto
a target person.
This way, we can appear to be playing tennis,
baseball or finally be able to perform a hundred
chin-ups.
Well, at least, on Instagram.
Now, look here!
Up here you see the target poses, and on the
left, the target subjects.
And between them, we see the output of this
algorithm with the target subjects taking
these poses.
As you see, the algorithm is quite consistent
in a sense that during walking, we often encounter
the same pose, which results in a very similar
image.
That’s exactly the kind of consistency that
we’re looking for!
Remarkably, this algorithm is also able to
synthesize angles of these target subjects
that it hadn’t seen before.
For instance, the backside of this person
was never shown to the algorithm and it correctly
guesses interesting details, like the belt
of this character to continue around the waist.
Really cool, I love it!
We can also put these characters in a virtual
environment and animate them there.
Now, this work, like most papers that explore
something completely new, is raw and experimental.
Clearly, there are issues with occlusions,
flickering, and the silhouettes of the characters
give the trick away.
Anyone looking at this footage can tell in
a second that it is not real.
The reason I am so excited about this is that
now, we finally see that this is a viable
concept, and it will provide fertile grounds
for new followup research works to be improved
upon.
Two more papers down the line, it will probably
work in HD and look significantly better.
Just imagine how amazing that would be for
movies, computer games and telepresence applications.
Sign me up!
And, computer graphics research has a vast
body of papers on how to illuminate these
characters to appear as if they were really
there in this environment.
Will this be done with computer graphics,
or through AI?
I am really keen to see how these fields will
come together to solve such a challenging
problem.
What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!